if if you and your neighbor are fighting
with each other and then I walk up to
you and I hand you a big old pile of
rocks and I tell you where to throw them
do you think your neighbor is gonna be
like that guy's not involved at all he's
gonna be like this dude is the one so
we're arming Ukraine we're telling them
where to shoot their missiles yeah the
United States provided the Intel to
Ukraine to sink the Black Sea Flagship
of Russia the idea that Russia as Putin
is going man how is how is Ukraine
beating us it's absurd Putin is saying
NATO is at war with us using the
ukrainians as cannon fodder American
citizens as quote unquote volunteers
military trained and armed are on the
ground in in it's it's the most
ridiculous thing in the world but people
live in this reality where because
there's no formal declaration that means
United States veteran troops armed by
the United States
that means we're not actually at War